hey everybody i'm josh wolfe and welcome
to dream pod today
on the show my ultimate
dream guest pop icon
rock star philanthropist please put
together your hands from my
favorite guest miley cyrus
all right so miley let's just get right
into it i guess my first question would
be
were you ever at dinner at the
helmsworth
household and look across the table of
chris and think
damn it i think i
i think i picked the wrong one
how old is too old for
a grown man to show up at your concert
by himself
um you know i am a huge fan um
i actually have two wrecking balls
any chance you climb on them with me
huh that song is so catchy you know so
when you were a kid
um was your first word dad
mom or mullet your dad is billy ray
cyrus
when he cut that mullet did he keep it
can i have your dad's mullet is your
brother as weird as he seems to be
seriously your brother seems like the
kind of guy who would have a pet dragon
is that true
so i know you took a jump into hip-hop a
couple of years ago
and then took a um a quick hop
out um are there any other musical
genres that you're
thinking about stealing from
[Music]
[Music]
you